[Music]
this is how I plan to retire when we
move to Brazil shaky tremor smokestack
but no but you want to start it how
would [ __ ] crazy I'm in though let's
go let's go
well I just sold his car so let's take
care of it
if you sell your car how are we supposed
to get to rock the bells today not going
to a concert we're going to the concert
grow up to be IP takes 300 would you pay
me 300 dollars if I perform sexual
favors on your body kill one yo you call
me about tickets your last two I got man
fine let's go oh well okay okay we get a
dumpy on
what happened man no I stole two tickets
and some moon rocks from some guy in
crisis are you gonna go to the concert
later you were hit on the drug dealers
girlfriend I saw this in a movie once
what happened after he is killed by a
boyfriend fingers crossed it works out
better for you
only 2% of people who get stuck up in
robberies actually get shot that's a
word
brazilian is my favorite porn search
word before drunk and amateur yeah I
don't know what it is about amateur but
I like it a lot I think it's just more
authentic so I can be here to send me
something do it within ten hundred
percent
[Music]
you see that show aren't you curious
about where it came from I'm gonna get
you home in a way